Christian nationalism is something we've
spoken about a lot on the program
Christian nationalism is very generally
speaking of you where you believe that
Christianity should be not only one of
many religions that people in their
private lives can choose to follow but
directly connected to the law of the
land and civil government Christian
nationalism includes the idea that the
doctrine of Christianity should be first
and foremost and in the Forefront of
what determines what are our civil laws
and civil government now congresswoman
Lauren bobert from Colorado who recently
just barely barely barely won
re-election she recently made some
comments about Jesus and Christianity
and it's really the stuff of nightmares
she spoke about the end times and the
Rapture and let's look at the clip first
but I I want you to just have in mind
and I know I've said this before and
people get offended what is the line
between religion and delusional mental
illness
when it comes to the sorts of stuff she
talks about I don't pretend to know the
answer but let's listen to what she said
and uh one thing that I love uh just an
analogy maybe maybe it's true or maybe
it's not about the second coming of
Jesus I've heard stories of you know
people believing that Christians are
going to be
um hiding out in caves and you know and
just um lockdown maybe maybe it's a
lockdown maybe it's a government
lockdown but they're shut in and they
beg for Jesus to come back he comes back
and rescues them I don't think that
that's the way it's going to be
if if the Old Testament is a type and a
shadow of the New Testament and you look
at the Exodus from Egypt Pharaoh he was
the one who called
for God to get his people he said get
your people out of here and I believe if
if that type and Shadow is true for the
New Testament the church God's people
will be out in such a great horse that
Satan himself will call for the second
coming of Jesus who say I cannot do a
thing in this Earth with your people
here when you come and get them
come on Wow incredibly powerful stuff
now I really need you to understand what
she's talking about here this you know
second coming of Jesus stuff
Resurrection Rapture end times this is
all you know there's different flavors
and I know no matter which summary I
give someone will write in and say David
you're misunderstanding this or that
aspect of it remember there's a thousand
versions of this but it is some
combination of there is going to be some
kind of end time event
where the Christians that are alive and
the resurrected Believers are going to
rise in the clouds and here on Earth bad
things are going to happen in some of
these versions all of the Jews die and
some of these virgin virgins versions
000 Jews survive there's ever everything
under the sun
it's all pretty Bonkers okay for from
just an Earthly perspective and it is
apparently in some circles not only
acceptable but welcomed to hear elected
officials talking in this way and they
use these beliefs to inform
um what they believe the law should be
for example the very same place that
Lauren bobert gets the ideas you just
heard she gets her ideas about abortion
which then she uses to say here's what
the law should be even though we're
supposed to have separation of church
and state so comments like these are
just completely appalling and her desire
to inject this sort of stuff into civil
government is an obvious violation of
the separation of church and state it if
if if she got her way it would lead to
unofficial discrimination and
marginalization of non-christians of
non-religious people altogether and it
is one of the scariest things that is
going on right now as a movement within
the Republican party yeah Maga stuff
it's wacky it's scary space lasers all
of it right it's crazy but the Christian
nationalism stuff is particularly
dangerous here's another clip from the
same interview this was the faith in
action podcast I guess Lauren bobert
says God tells her re-election would be
like the Prophet Elijah in the Bible
defeating the prophets of all this is
what this is what God said to her I
don't know if this was like at a cafe at
a bar or in private prayer wow totally
um
can do that they called him a
conservative right um just allowed him
to Define himself as that it's bizarre
um but I won again with 51 of the vote
barely I just took a lot longer to get
there but you know throughout all of
this um I was telling you you know God
was really pressing on my heart the
story of Elijah okay she's saying God
spoke to her okay I really need
everybody to understand she is saying
that a man in the sky I think they still
say he's a man of sorts or a masculine
entity in the sky
spoke to her about specific passages
in the context of her re-election he
said the true God will answer by fire
and those who worshiped
I said ball I guess it's bail the true
God he said Elijah said prove it if Baal
is the true God tell him to answer by
fire and they're calling him for him
they're screaming they're hollering
they're cutting themselves or acting a
pool you know we've seen that like in
2020 riots and stuff right but
their God didn't show up Elijah was
mocking them yeah well maybe cry a
little bit louder maybe he can't hear
you maybe he's sleeping maybe he's on
vacation I love that so much
um and then he went he said you know
what I'm gonna do you one better I don't
want you to say that this is some kind
of fluke um some sort of combustion that
just happened I'm gonna drench the altar
with fire or with water three times fire
or water whichever three times he went
and drenched the altar with fire and God
with water and God still showed up by
fire and that's what he was showing me
with this election he said it may look
impossible in the natural that there
will not be a victory you may hear the
voices you may hear other people but I
am going to show up now of course these
are always stories that are that are
told with the hindsight of knowing how
the election turned up she barely won
and and she could have lost would she
still be telling the story listen God
came to me and he said your re-election
is going to be like when Prophet Elijah
defeated the prophets of Baal then she
loses oh I guess God was wrong no but
God God is never wrong
this is the sort of stuff even if they
don't say it that a lot of members of
Congress are thinking when they think
about how they are legislating now I
know many of you will write in and say
but you know David this it's really not
a big deal because you look at in Italy
everybody's Catholic you know although
elected officials are Catholic and it's
just no big deal it's really important
to understand that not all religions are
the same and I know lots of Italian
Catholics I have many italian Catholic
friends what it means to them to be
Catholic is a very different thing than
what it means for evangelicals like I
believe she's Evangelical Lauren bobert
to be Evangelical and the comfort that
folks like bobert have even despite the
separation of church and state that
we're supposed to have saying things
like we need Christian nationalism we
need the church to be guiding government
and all of the things I've covered her
saying over recent Years A lot of people
with some connection to reality would be
embarrassed to be on video saying the
things that Lauren bobert says not not
for the religious reasons but because it
would be seen as so inappropriate to
come out and say I believe that my
religion not just religion but my
religion not anybody else's not any
other religions should be dictating how
government works you talk to Catholic
politicians in Italy who are nominally
Catholic and would consider themselves
religious in the way that many Europeans
do they would be humiliated to be caught
saying things like what Lauren bobert
says so it's not all the same and it's a
really important thing to understand
this particular brand of Christian
nationalism that often comes from
born-again Christians and evangelicals
Etc
it's not just kind of wacky in terms of
the things they say it is but it's not
only that it also is extraordinarily
dangerous in terms of what it would mean
if they got their way and when you look
at what's happening in the Supreme Court
and Amy Coney Barrett and others who are
on that Court who at least to some
degree share a lot of these views you
realize that if things keep going the
direction that they've been going it's
not completely out of the question that
in some ways the bobert types could get
their way and that's a horrifying thing
to think about